[Music]
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my new Batman video there
was a new report that was published by
the direct website about their plans for
a new version of the Joker in Matt
Reeves Batman trilogy so we'll break it
all down there's a bunch of Easter eggs
if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos will do
a new Amazon giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave
all your predictions for the new version
of the Joker in the Batman movies so
starting with the really important stuff
first number 5 the direct website
published a report this past week
claiming that Matt Reeves isn't just
going to use a new version of the Joker
and his new Batman trilogy of movies
he's going to use the Joker character
way more in a much bigger way than any
previous Batman movie franchise before
not counting the TV series like Batman
the Animated Series or the live-action
TV series like Gotham or the Adam West
1966 Batman series because there were
multiple appearances from those versions
of the Joker we're really just talking
about the big movie franchises and even
though there's a lot of question about
whether or not we'll ever see Joaquin
Phoenix's Joker again in another movie
they've been talk about them doing it
there's been talk about them not doing
it he was great as that character but
Todd Phillips keeps saying that he never
intended for his Joker movie to
crossover with Robert Pattinson Batman
movies you just wanted to make fun of me
really good example of previous Joker's
though Heath Ledger only appeared as the
Joker once in the Dark Knight Jared Leto
technically only appeared in The Suicide
Squad film even though technically he's
the version of the Joker referenced in
the birds-of-prey movie he never
appeared on-screen during that Jack
Nicholson only appeared in the first
Michael Keaton Batman movie in 1989 fun
fact though had they continued with that
iteration of the Batman franchise in a
fifth Batman movie that would have been
titled Batman Unchained they had planned
to bring back Jack Nicholson's Joker as
a hallucination in Batman's mine filming
new footage with Jack Nicholson I think
we can all agree though that as cool as
that might have been to see him come
back and reprise his role we were much
better off moving to the Christopher
Nolan Dark Knight trilogy of Batman
films so number for this new Joker
report goes on to state that the plan
for this new version of the Joker is to
cast another major actor there been a
lot of rumors about who that could be
I'll mention
second in the Joker's story arc in the
new Batman trilogy of movies will be a
bigger version bigger buildup of say
like the Christopher Nolan Dark Knight
trilogy Joker with Heath Ledger so think
about the way that the Dark Knight
trilogy treated the Joker character at
the end of Batman Begins Gordon tells
Batman that a new costume crazy person
is serviced and literally is leaving
playing cards as calling cards shows him
the Joker playing card from a recent
crime scene and that just meant to be
the end tag scene teaser that the Joker
would be the main villain of the next
movie The Dark Knight Heath Ledger was
amazing in that but because he
unfortunately passed away before the
Dark Knight Rises was made they opted
not to do any Joker during that third
movie although after he did pass away
Heath Ledger's sisters apparently did an
interview claiming that he had told them
he planned a return in some fashion to
the Dark Knight Rises we don't really
know what his role would have been
during that movie given that Tom Hardy's
Bane was supposed to be in the main
villain if he would have teamed up with
him or just simply taken advantage of
all the chaos that he was causing in
Gotham so number 3 / this report the new
Robert Pattinson Batman movie version of
the Joker is supposed to be a more
drawn-out version of The Dark Knight
trilogy version of the Joker storyline
teased him at the end of the first movie
with a reference or a playing card
something small but obvious letting you
know that the Joker exists within this
universe he's simply too big to swerve
on they sell way too many toys make way
too much money to not do any kind of
Joker at all then he'd appear on screen
in some fashion during the Batman -
whatever that sequel winds up being but
he wouldn't be the main villain of that
movie like he was during the Dark Knight
he'd just be a side character in the way
they say like Colin Farrell has said
that his version of the penguin is in
the first Batman movie and has some
great scenes but he's not meant to be
the main villain and he doesn't have a
ton of scenes in terms of quantity
compared to some of the other villains
but they used that second Batman movie
to develop the new Joker character more
and then he becomes the main villain of
the 3rd Batman movie right now the
Robert Pattinson and Matt Reeves Batman
movies are only being described as a
trilogy so I don't know if they have
plans to do more Batman with Robert
Pattinson after that I think it just
depends on how things go I did a video
last week about how Warner Brothers has
a desire to do more Batman spin-off
movies for characters like the Riddler
and Catwoman given the success of the
Joaquin Phoenix standalone joke
Mubi so there will be more Batman
related movies even if they don't do a
fourth Robert Pattinson Batman movie but
number two you've also probably seen the
rumors about who might wind up playing
that new version of the Joker I've seen
a lot of recent speculation about Willem
Dafoe although I think he's just a fan
theory right now more than an actual
possibility Willem Dafoe and Robert
Pattinson just did the lighthouse movie
together a while ago they were a great
pair together Willem Dafoe is an amazing
actor he's played some amazing villains
his version of the Green Goblin in the
Tobey Maguire spider-man movies is still
iconic you're an amazing creature
spider-man you and I are not so
different but I don't think that the
type of characters that he typically
plays are in the tone of what Matt
Reeves is talking about with his Batman
movie he said that his new Batman movie
or multiple new movies if we're talking
about a trilogy are totally somewhere
between Tim Burton's more stylized
Batman Christopher Nolan's more
realistic Batman and what I would call
the heightened reality of the neo-gothic
Batman the Animated Series if you've
seen some of the set pictures from the
Batman movie this past year you pricing
some of the architecture to sort of
reflects that sort of a little bit more
gothic than what you saw during
Christopher Nolan's Batman movies but
not quite so crazy is what we saw during
the Tim Burton films so until they
actually cast someone and we see him on
screen I'm imagining a joker somewhere
between Jack Nicholson's Joker and Heath
Ledger's Joker terrorizes yes Joaquin
Phoenix would be amazing in the new
Batman movies but I've already done a
couple videos explaining how Todd
Phillips doesn't want his Joker to
crossover with the Batman movies he
seems completely opposed to it the other
new Joker actor that everyone's been
talking about this year has actually
been Johnny Depp and it's just a rumor
right now I don't have any strong
feelings about him particularly
personally as long as whoever this new
Joker winds up being just delivers a
great performance I don't care who Matt
Reeves winds up picking I tried to have
too many expectations like that because
when Heath Ledger was first announced as
the Joker for Dark Knight the internet
just completely hated the idea cut to a
couple years later after the movie and
he became the most beloved Joker of all
time next to Mark Hamill's Joker I'll
show ya when
down these these civilized people
they'll eat each other the exact same
thing happened for the joaquin phoenix
joker when he was announced to people
freaked out and suddenly he's now one of
the new best jokers of all time
so speaking of which number one my
favorite versions of the joker if you
include all the TV series including the
animated ones the spin-off movies there
have been at least sixteen different
major versions of the joker so i'm just
gonna do my top five in reverse order
here all these are great performances by
the way starting with number five the
cesar romero joker from the 1966 Adam
West Batman series he's a classic
through and through if you've never seen
any of his Joker be sure to check it out
at some point number four the Cameron
Monaghan Jerome version of the Joker
from Gotham even though I didn't like
everything that they did with that TV
series I feel like he did something
really interesting with that TV version
of the Joker
number three is Jack Nicholson's Joker
from the 1989 Batman movie even though
his version of the Joker was very
different from the canonical comic book
Joker backstory he just delivered an
iconic performance and he was my first
movie Joker that I ever saw as a child
ever dance with the devil in the pale
moonlight I always ask that of all my
brain I just like the sound of it number
two was Joaquin Phoenix's Joker from the
Joker movie however you feel about the
movie itself his performance was amazing
Murray one small thing yeah when you
bring me out can you introduce me as
Joker and as you probably guess my
number one pick is actually a tie
between Heath Ledger's Joker from The
Dark Knight in Mark Hamill's Joker from
Batman the Animated Series normally
people only think about the live-action
movies when you think about the best
versions of the characters but Mark
Hamill has one of the most iconic Joker
port rails in history from any of the
movies any of the TV series in Batman
the Animated Series itself is one of the
best TV series of any TV series in
history Batman mask of the phantasm is
also one of the best Batman movies of
all time it just happens to be an
animated movie
[Music]
next year after we hopefully get to
watch this new Batman movie I will rear
ank my new Batman movie tier list but
post all your reactions in the comments
below who do you want to play this new
version of the Joker and who is your
favorite version of the Joker right now
the Batman movie and pretty much every
other movie that went on break because
of the virus is getting ready to start
filming again this summer so as we get
more details about the movie and learn
more about the story I'll do more big
Batman bonus videos but leave all your
requests in the comments below
everyone click here for my other
brand-new Batman trilogy video about the
villains and the new spin-off movies and
click here for that brand new Bill and
Ted face the music trailer with Keanu
Reeves thank you so much for watching
everyone stays safe I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]